it's the middle of the night let's
imagine and we've been on the earth for
about three months a lot is still very
unclear we are profoundly helpless
barely able to move our own head and
utterly at the mercy of others the
sources of our suffering and joy life
far outside our understanding hugely
powerful needs passed through us at
regular intervals and we have no way of
making sense of them to ourselves let
alone of communicating them reliably to
others a minute ago we were asleep in a
dark enveloping warmth
now we're awake bereft isolated and very
uncomfortable there seems to be a pain
somewhere in our stomach but the agony
is more general we are lonely and
profoundly sad the room is dark and
there's a mysterious set of shadows on
the wall that appear and vanish at
random in a rising panic we start to
scream out in the darkness nothing
happens we pause to recover our breath
and then scream even louder our lungs
strain with the effort still nothing and
the darkness and loneliness grow ever
more threatening now true desperation
sets in this feels like the end of
everything good and true and we scream
as if to ward off death at last just
when it seems we could not go on any
further that door opens a warm orange
light is turned on it's a familiar face
they smile at us say the name they often
use around us pick us up and put us
against their shoulder we can hear a
familiar heart beating next to ours and
a warm hand caressing the top of our
head they gently move us to and fro and
sing a tender sweet song our sobs start
to abate we pull a weak smile it feels
like the vicious demons and merciless
goblins have been sent packing and that
life could be bearable after all
soothing is one of the kindest gestures
that humans ever perform for one another
it must lie close to the core of love
and is what can make the difference
between a desire to die and the capacity
to endure awkwardly it tends to be very
hard to soothe ourselves
less we are first usually in childhood
been properly soothed by someone else a
capacity for self soothing is the legacy
of a history of nurture if we have been
picked up enough times early on and
sufficiently reassured in a midst of
panic that we will make it then one part
of the mind learns the art and can
practice it on the other and eventually
on people outside us too at moments of
crisis we find ourselves able to access
a voice that calms the waves of fear and
the blows of self-hatred we can sort
this out
we'll have a conversation with them
people understand and screw them if they
don't what matters is you you are good
and valuable we have available an
unflustered resolute response as much to
the most awful events as to routine
panics we have a faith that we can
endure that something will show up and
that we don't deserve the worst
reflecting on the art of soothing may
bring into focus just how much we are
missing
we're not mysteriously deficient we were
brought up by adults who were themselves
not soothed we need to grow attentive
and deeply sympathetic to the missing
bits of our own psyche it's because we
didn't benefit from soothing that life
is so much harder than it should be that
nowadays rejection is so bitter social
media is so frightening disapproval
feels so fatal ambiguity is so
unbearable sleep feels so unearned
holidays are so worrying the caresses of
others feel so alien and so many of our
days and nights are rocked by what feel
like near-death experiences there are
one must believe substitutes and
opportunities for catching up we can
have a cause to music Diaries beds baths
but most importantly other people
however seeking out the sort of people
who can sue us maybe the hardest step we
may mistake a capacity to soothe for
weakness or naivety we may take the
suitor for a fool we may need soothing
so much
we find ourselves unable to ask for it
nicely shout encounter productively
instead or else we withdraw into
defensive independence because help
feels like it hasn't come soon enough
those in the greatest need of soothing
often have no idea of what is missing no
sensible way of articulating their need
and a dogged suspicion of kindness were
it to be offered to them we should
strive not to make things constantly
scarier in our own minds than they are
in reality we should offer soothing
continuously to others and insist to the
more skeptical and parched parts of our
own minds that they too deserve one day
to be the beneficiaries of kindness and
reassurance
thank you for watching remember to like
the video and subscribe to our channel
for more our calm prompt cards can help
us to find serenity
despite daily anxieties and frustrations
to find out more click on the link now